I'd say the TMNT brand is doing as well
now as it ever has multiple Major Video
Games lined up a new movie that was a
smash hit a brand new TV series on the
way and hey look they're in fortnite but
since they've debuted in the inky black
and white world of 80s Indie Comics
they've certainly had high highs and
Incredibly low lows let's take a look at
the lowest they got and keep the TMNT
brand humble that's right we digging
into Next Mutation an embarrassment to
turtle fans everywhere and a permanent
mark on the face of an otherwise great
franchise this show is often used as a
punching bag by those who even remember
it but I've never seen it myself until
now join me on this journey as we inject
26 episodes of Mutagen infused cringe
directly into our wrinkly rubber muscles
hey let's just take a quick intermission
do you like Spider-Man do you like video
games well on March 1st I'm going to be
hosting a live autograph signing stream
exclusively on my Channel with the cast
of Marvel Spider-Man 2 Naji Jeter Steven
oou young Jim Peri my boy Yuri lenthal
and even the great Tony Todd will all be
there if you go to my link in the
description you can purchase an
autograph from one two or all of them to
sign during the event and then mail
straight to your door after it's over
you can personalize the autographs or
have them made out to a friend or family
member as a gift during the signing I'll
be interviewing the cast of the game so
post to me your burning questions you'd
like to ask each of them here in the
comments and I'll take a couple of good
ones into account and ask them during
the stream don't forget it's on March 1
and you won't want to miss this
pre-sales are in the link in the
description buying any of the autographs
is a great way to support the cast and
me if you want to do that if you think
I'd cool if you like me so don't miss
out after the popularity of the
liveaction films Rec seeded with each
installment of the original trilogy as
did the quality of the movies themselves
the TMNT franchise needed another hit to
to Breathe new life into it the cartoon
was a smash hit billion dooll crazy
success like no other so why not attempt
another Fay into the world of Television
the resulting series is a sort of pseudo
continuation of the movie Set a little
bit later when the Turtles are about to
turn 18 Shredder who is still alive
somehow
oops mentions slicing off Splinter's ear
and has the same scar on his face plus
there's no connection at all to the
robot ninjas or interdimensional brain
aliens or the Animated Series so I think
they were hoping this would come off as
the next chapter for the liveaction
Turtles TMNT 2007 has its problems but I
take that as the part four any day over
this when my editor Ben suggested we
finally do this review I realized that I
didn't know anything about this show
except for the basics being that it's
not very good Venus is a thing and Power
Rangers cross over but in all my years
as a turtle fan I I've never heard
anyone sit down and genuinely talk in
detail about the content of this series
like the characters and the storylines
and the production aspects of it so I
want to take a genuine look at what's
under Next Mutation shell as a fan of
the series and talk about it seriously
as if it was just another one of the
movies or something uh you know Ser as
seriously as I'm capable TMNT Next
Mutation is about the turtles when
they're slightly older 17 about to be 18
years old oh gone when they're facing
new threats after their more traditional
foes have already been beaten when they
were younger during the five-part
opening Arc of the series they meet a
fifth mutated turtle who is washed away
from them during their origin story and
conveniently also was found by a kindly
old martial artist in Chinatown when you
were exposed to the ooze and then
floated Downstream into Chinatown where
you were lucky enough to be found by
Chong e Chong e Chong e She showcases
her value as a member of the team by
basically basically one-shotting the
shredder once and for all in the second
episode with him finally out of the way
Shredder is replaced by a new villain
dragon lord who is basically the same as
Shredder but he's a lizard for being in
such a hurry to introduce new villains
they sure do adhere to the exact
archetypes of the old ones spiky murder
man sniveling scientist guy tiny little
freak man with a funny voice that's the
main bad guy's comedic foil dragon lord
and his evil minions want to find and
eat the turtles to gain some kind of
mutant Magic combination power up to
rule the world this did not need to be a
five-part storyline to convey all this
information like this is a lot of setup
for essentially just well here's damn
near the same villain that we usually
fight but this time there's a girl here
too five parts why the first thing that
sticks out to me is the waste of the
premise that the turtles are a little
bit older and doing new stuff now
because for the most part they don't
really act or do anything differently
than they did when they were 15 I know
it's not that big of an age Gap they're
not 30 but like you could have done
something the only new development is
that Mikey runs a Pirate Radio Station
out of his car where he tells kids to
stay off drugs but also Fight The
Establishment oddly enough I don't feel
like any of these voices for the turtles
are bad it's just that they're all
miscast for the specific Turtle they're
playing raph's voice would be a better
fit for Mikey so like you're mad at me
right yo dudes what's the Happ Mikey's
voice would be a better fit for
Donatello 3 th000 horsepower pure
turbocharge fuel injected Madness
Donatello's voice would be a better fit
for Leonardo you're Warrior WRA I say
it's green time let's save Dr que
together Leonardo's voice would be a
better fit for Raphael I can't
concentrate if you're going to keep
blabbing and blowing stuff up how'd they
screw that up four times in a row
because she grew up in China Venus has a
thick Chinese accent wonder if that's
something the voice actress herself had
no that's a white Canadian woman I
didn't give Kevin Clash a hard time I'll
give her a pass but it's still kind of
funny sound effects sound effects sound
effects they never let up on their sound
effects wake
up
can while the original 1990 movie did a
really solid job of selling the illusion
of the mutated humanoid animals with
practical effects this gives you the
feeling that you're watching Barney the
dinosaur the puppeteering and
animatronics
are even for a TV budget Jim Hon's
Workshop this is not characters heads
look like dead eyed slack jawed rubber
helmets with flapping mandibles that
never resemble the phones of their
speech sometimes they go completely
crosseyed even the characters that are
clearly hand puppets don't have proper
lip sync I almost wonder if the dialogue
was often changed after the fact from
what they recorded on set because it's
so far off your mother ever tell you not
to play with sharp objects I could
expect some dubbing problems from Power
Rangers because that was filmed in a
different language with a different
storyline and they just reused footage
in a completely different context but
this was made in English Venus has the
most obvious case of eyeh holes under
her bandana I've ever seen well that was
until I saw this shot of Raph on the
bike I get it's a safety thing but I
simply would not have used that shot
Silver's mouth is really stiff and the
makeup on the mad scientist Dr que is a
little hard on the eyes you can always
see where the makeup ends and his real
skin begins on his neck and it kills the
illusion that he's this crazy old guy
you can't fool me that's a young
handsome guy under there the most
impressive visual effect in the show is
that they somehow chroma all five
turtles in that one shot in the intro
what color were they standing against to
achieve that that's legitimately
impressive to me as another half that's
always using green screen effects in my
own cheap ass show okay all that being
said about the costumes I still think
all the costume performers are putting
in the work to make the characters look
really Lively everyone moves with so
much energy and has such expressive body
language I'd say the best performance in
the whole show has to be Scott mcneel
who you may know is the voice of
Wolverine Piccolo and half the cast of
Beast Wars he plays a low rent scraggly
craving the Hunter type guy named bone
steel and he's a definite standout his
voice is so insane sounding and he's so
animated and wacky like Jim Cary Grinch
vibes from this character I could watch
this guy for hours he's pretty much the
save and Grace of the whole show sh
tooth long dead but oh so useful that's
what I love about
Critters okay I know the chances of this
are probably really low but do any of
you in the audience know how I can
contact Scott mcneel maybe a business
email or some social media or a website
to send inquiries he's one of my
all-time favorite voice actors and I'd
love to work with him in a video like I
did with Yuri lenthal Gary chalk and Cal
DOD just putting it out there in case I
also like the yeti Crime Boss named
silver and how he and his crew have this
colorful Dick Tracy aesthetic he's even
voiced by Gary chalk hit it Prime
subscribe to Xavier for more videos like
this one
though I do wish Silver was a villain in
one of the animated shows instead
because his concept and design are great
but the mask is really expressionless
imagine him in the art style of the80s
cartoon or even rise of the TMNT and if
we're comparing it to the cartoons I
find it really weird how we went from
one of the most recognizable intro theme
songs of all time to this bad indistinct
aerobics Dance Mix
trash
for most Turtles themes the lyrics are
always about emphasizing the uniqueness
of their personalities the 2003 one was
about their moral code AS ninjas and
their Unity as brothers what is this
songs say about them
ninjas they're fantastic and never
Panic something about fighting until the
morning I guess it says they're Brave
and dedicated even though most episodes
start with them trying to avoid helping
people or dealing with conflict of any
kind if it doesn't directly impact them
for having 26 episodes you think this
series could have had more villains but
it's just the five main ones dragon lord
and his goons the evil scientist Dr que
working with them uh big monkey crime
man Scott mcneel showing us how it's
done and this hot thousand-year-old
vampire lady that shows up in the last
major arc of the show she's also got her
two sidekicks Jubilee the Explorer and
avat AR Ang after hitting puberty
Turtles ging Bales not packs down from
there because the turtles are often
fighting the same villains in the same
handful of locations and set pieces
these episodes start to blend together
and don't leave much of an impression
the one that stuck out to me as having
some potential was that they actually
found the shredder again after Venus
blew his mind he's like a half crazed
homeless man that has no Clan anymore
because the foot lost their loyalty for
him Splinter takes pity on him and
brings him home with the intention to
nurse him back to health and they get to
explore that weird complicated
relationship a little bit but it ends on
a teaser for more storylines that never
came to pass where Shredder regains his
full awareness and powers and laughs
maniacally into the night first this
then Batman versus TMNT this guy needs
to stop trying to do sequel bait please
don't fail please don't fail please
don't fail I also feel like they didn't
get the memo about Raphael's personality
because he doesn't really have any an or
anger he's only sarcastic sometimes he's
just like a second Mikey that's really
bad at following directions and is
obsessed with his motorcycle he
basically makes his bike his entire
personality and talks about it
constantly any you Chumps put a scratch
on my bike you foot in the bill nearly
every episode has a scene of him getting
told to not go outside for the night but
he blows them off and then rides his
bike around the city all night shouting
like a dumb hick and then crashing it
into the episode's main plot it keeps
happening over and over often with
reused footage at least they managed to
keep his sibling rivalry with Leo even
to the point that there's an entire
episode dedicated to it the title of
that episode is like brothers even
though they're not Brothers which is it
commit to something jeez oh Jesus this
show actually has two clip show episodes
and the second one is the series finale
o I'm surprised they even had enough
Clips to sh show sometimes this show can
go multiple episodes without a single
identifiable human being and all the
action is just suit and puppet
characters a series like this one almost
always has a normal human sidekick
character to just be like a relatable
regular person for the audience to latch
on to okay Beast Wars made a great case
that you don't need that character
archetype if the Fantastical creatures
are written with enough personality and
pathos but this show makes the case that
they can be really needed to flesh out a
flatly written cast of characters having
no April or Casey or any regular humans
at all for them to hang out with just
makes the show feel bizarre and
disconnected from reality sometimes you
need a break from every single character
being an anthro puppet monster in a cave
it's like a violent Fraggle Rock except
not cool cuz that sounds really cool the
best human character is Splinter's
friend Andre he's a blind old man that
he plays chess with in the park who
doesn't know Splinter's a mutant because
he's only heard his voice though he's
only in two episodes total I liked him a
lot hey wait a minute I know why I like
this character he's ripped off wholesale
from Hudson's buddy Jeffrey Robbins and
gargoyles it's the exact same character
in Dynamic come
on all right let's talk about the light
blue bandana wearing elephant in the
room fenus Deo seems like an innocuous
addition to the team at first glance but
would you believe that her entire
existence actually drove away wedge
between the TMNT co-creators Eastman and
lared for a good long time Kevin Eastman
and Peter lared were co-workers who
became friends then creative Partners
working on the original black and white
TMNT comic back in the80s once the comic
blew up and then the cartoon and
merchandise became million-dollar
Avenues they both reacted to the fame
and money very differently Peter L was a
little bit older he'd already settled
down and had a family he was more
financially responsible while Kevin
Eastman was younger excited to get get
out there and find his next big thing
after the turtles and he bought a tank
that's real look it up but they both
initially had an agreement on one
steadfast rule no matter what do not add
a fifth ninja turtle there had been this
suggestion from fans why don't youe of a
fifth Turtle but we both always express
the opinion that we thought it was a
stupid idea female or otherwise because
once you do that the floodgates are open
it stops being a story about the bond of
four brothers and then they become more
like Transformers where there's a core
cast that's always there and then an
ever expanding infinite rotating cast of
new turtle themed characters with
different gimmicks being shoved in once
you have five why not six or seven or 15
and then it just loses the very basic
appeal of these four tightly knit
well-rounded characters but after so
many years of the turtle success had
passed and both of them were in a very
different place in their lives Kevin
Eastman didn't feel as strongly about
this rule nor did did he feel as
strongly about the franchise as a whole
at the time when the creators of the
show pitched to him the idea of a female
Ninja Turtle getting added he signed off
on it without L's consent because he
just didn't think it was that big of a
deal and historically it wasn't but
Venus de Milo became sort of a symbol of
how these two guys had drifted apart
over the years they started talking less
they weren't working as closely together
as they used to and they had different
opinions on the future of the brand and
Peter lar hated this character like so
much you couldn't even joke about it to
him he was sore about it for many years
to kind of finalize their breakup
Eastman sold his shares of the ownership
of TMNT to LS so he could detach himself
from Turtles and go strike out on his
own to start his own Comics company lard
still had a lot of passion and love for
the turtles and it led him to being
heavily in control during the production
of the 2003 TMNT series which ended up
being almost a onetoone adaptation of
the80s comic with some extra stuff
thrown in to keep it been interesting so
ultimately the turtles franchise
wouldn't take too much of a hit because
of all this Venus stuff and it did lead
to better things but it's a shame that
Venus as a concept was apparently a big
point of contention between two guys who
were both really talented and worked so
well together in the past and for having
such big waves on the TMNT brand people
don't remember much about her or this
show so what's the deal with her exactly
how does she fit into this team from a
story standpoint well
not well you're a full-fledged mutant
hottie I think I'm in love you spare me
and I'll lead you to her she's quite a
trophy how do Ive girl turtle thank you
we can make a fortune renting Venus I
don't have my trunks so you have to
promise not to peek unless of course you
can help yourself oh God was this a Dan
Harmon production no you wouldn't even
add the red conon so I am not your
sister no you and I are just mutant boy
and mutant girl
no Revelation I feel like anyone who
would seriously sit down and write this
dialogue making all four of the turtles
completely unrelated to each other just
for the sake of a potential love
triangle and romance so it's not
incestuous needs to take a serious look
at their life and ask what they're doing
if I could think of one of the main
themes of Ninja Turtles above all else
it's Brotherhood Brothers in Arms
Brothers biologically Brothers in the
way they act towards each other raised
together in a family like Brothers It's
So baked in it's like the most important
thing maybe and stripping that away so
Leo can awkwardly try to a female Ninja
Turtle in this series aimed at
5-year-olds it's just like the most
insane and horrible thing ever what the
is it with Leonardo and this borderline
incest that's twice now how much of
a goon brain do you have to be to make a
shapely quote unquote sexy Ninja Turtle
with mamalian breasts sculpted into her
shell I hate this redcon because it
makes everything so weird and it all has
this uncomfortable sexual tension now
why is Leo sitting like that while
Donnie polishes his sword for him I hate
it I'll share my chi pool with
[Music]
you you can do whatever you want your
Wattpad fanfiction but like keep it out
of the official product that goes to you
batg girl and Batman shippers too you
Knuckleheads so if we were to take this
seriously how do you actually add a
fifth ninja turtle well they need to
have a distinct personality that can
mingle well with the others all four of
the original guys look the same do kind
of the same thing but they sure don't
act the same they all have very distinct
personalities to distinguish them but
Venus's personality is that
she's kind of stoic and takes her
training seriously she's just a
secondary Leo a lot of the time now she
doesn't have a specific weapon that can
be associated with her so she is more
connected to the spiritual and mystical
side of marshal arts but Splinter
usually fills that role with his
meditation and astral projecting and
talking about mystical stuff I really
can't think of anything she actually
contributes to the group dynamic that
isn't already done successfully by
another character uh her biggest
addition to the comedy is that she
doesn't have a perfect grasp of the
English language and the guys have to
keep correcting
her
go oh that's hockey Venus there's one
episode where she and Donatello kind of
have this rivalry because he's all about
logic and Science and she's more about
Vibes and Magic that was kind of
something but it only happens in one
episode it really sucks that she doesn't
have a weapon because instead her
gimmick is that she has poorly defined
magic powers that can be used in any
scenario she can do anything and I I
don't mean that uh she's got a
convenient aptitude for flying
spaceship's way I mean she can literally
warp reality and do anything with her
magic she can shoot lightning from her
hands she can track people's Aura she
can see into the past she can teleport a
whole group of people she can read and
Destroy her mind she can sense where a
lost candy bar is under the couch
cushion from across the room you'd think
having a kind of No Limits mystical
Doctor Strange character would make the
fight scenes more interesting but she's
mostly fighting hand to hand and like
everyone else it's pretty clunky even if
they emote well with their bodies and
the dialogue scenes often times
compensating for the stiff masks the
actors in the costumes don't seem
comfortable fighting in these suits
there's this sense that they can't see
what they're doing the costume is too
heavy and the choreography is kind of an
afterthought they barely use their
weapons for obvious reasons but most of
the time it's like light Looney Tunes
type stuff while they just shout related
puns out loud you look tired maybe you
ought to just sit this one up here you
go the editing is really quick and this
show can give Ed Ed and Eddie a run for
its money with the sound effects but all
of that fails to actually give it any
kind of energy and impact it seems like
the sound effects are a crutch for how
slow and wonky they are we went from
Hong Kong action Cinema style fights to
the turtles looking clumsy heavy and
like they don't have much training I
mean the costumes were just as bad for
the actors to wear in the actual movie
itself but they were able to work around
it the Next Mutation turtles look like
they're about to fall on their back and
get stuck that is until the Power
Rangers cross over it's well documented
that this Show's Turtles teamed up with
the Power Rangers but no one told me it
was actually awesome this episode has an
actual plot with stakes and drama and
the fight scenes have real choreography
in this one the turtles move like
they're actually skilled Fighters with
superhuman abilities they're jumping
like 10 ft in the air doing actual
coordinated moves with each other and
with the Power Rangers and they look
like they can see what they're doing you
could tell Power Rangers had a better
fight coordinator or a better stunt team
or something definitely more money to
drop on the fight scenes because this is
the best the Next Mutation Turtles ever
looked plus the sets are a little bit
more expensive the lighting is more
pleasant to look at and the photography
makes the suits look a little bit more
flattering if Next Mutation was this
level of quality 100% of the time it
probably wouldn't have been looked down
on so hard by history you could really
tell that Power Rangers was in its prime
around this time and had some budget to
show off at least relative for a
liveaction TV show for kids so while
it's sad that the only time the Next
Mutation Turtles actually looked cool
was in someone else's show they got to
be exciting at least once I wouldn't
recommend most
or any of Next Mutation because of how
low effort and low quality it is but I'd
at least recommend this one episode and
maybe someone out there could just make
like a compilation of scenes of bone
steel because those are worth watching
Next Mutation isn't a memorable or
interesting show it's full of episodes
where it's kind of hard to remember what
happens in them the characters aren't
developed in any meaningful way and the
action is severely lacking it was one of
the major factors in causing a divide
between the tmnt's co-creators and it
can generally be seen as an embarrassing
mark on an otherwise spotless brand well
coming out of the Shell's tour isn't
that great either while this series
represents a sort of dark period of
growing pains for the Juggernaut of a
franchise none of its negative
contributions were permanent thankfully
one day decades later Eastman and L
would reconnect and begin working
together again on stories like the last
Ronin which I mean everyone talks about
that and Kevin Eastman would come back
to write the now Mass massively
successful IDW Ninja Turtles comic
that's nearing its 150th issue
conclusion storyline and the concept of
a female fifth ninja turtle would be
used more successfully on a character
named jenica in those very same Comics
leading the way for Venus de Milo to
make a return in a form where she's
actually kind of cool and interesting
instead of horribly horribly
embarrassing I guess the main takeaway
from Next Mutation is that everything
has its highs and lows while this was
the first major low point for the TMNT
uh and you know the third movie they
persevered and got to some major highs
after this one that made us forget they
even struggled at all even when God
turns you into a horrible clumsy
uncoordinated mutant with rubbery skin
and locked jaw there's still a chance
that you can hang out with the Power
Rangers and look badass for 22 minutes
and then one day be in a funny pickle
commercial I hope that inspires you
somehow I always get mad at YouTube for
not putting my vide videos in the
subscription box because people will
comment finally Xavier uploads again
after all these years not knowing three
other videos came out within the last
month already so maybe that stupid Bell
icon thing will help you remember I
exist if you want other ways to support
the channel you can always go hit up
that patreon for early videos and
exclusive stuff because it's just a
dollar I'm not kidding it's only $1
Isn't that cool if just 5% of the people
subscribed to me donated only $1 a month
I could make videos even faster and keep
my house you can also check out our
merch on tuu or just buy some of my
random stuff on eBay I have a pretty
substantial collection of old toys that
are still in the box in perfect
condition so go take a look in case you
find something you like and lastly since
this is a YouTube video and you probably
play fortnite drop my Creator code
Xavier GM next time you buy a silly
dance or a cool character skin really
helps me out uh see you next
[Music]
time